So explain this recording and when it was made.
那么解释一下这段录音，以及它是何时制作的。
This recording was made in September of 2014 at the Odeon in TriBeCa in New York City.
这段录音是在 2014 年 9 月于纽约市翠贝卡的 Odeon 餐厅制作的。
That's a restaurant.
那是一家餐厅。
It's a restaurant.
Reid Cherlin was writing a story for Rolling Stone back then, about this not-so-well-known-at-the-time bomb-throwing right-wing news website, Breitbart News. And he was at the Odeon to interview one of the guys who ran it, Steve Bannon. Bannon's now the chief strategist for the President of the United States. So what's he like?
里德·切林 (Reid Cherlin) 当时正在为《滚石》杂志撰写一篇报道，关于那个在当时还不太出名、极具攻击性的右翼新闻网站——布赖特巴特新闻 (Breitbart News)。他当时就在 Odeon 采访经营该网站的人之一，史蒂夫·班农 (Steve Bannon)。班农现在是美国总统的首席策略师。那么他是个什么样的人呢？
He was very engaging. I've told this story to friends over the course of the past few months, and I think I'm always struggling for the right adjectives. I feel like I want to say charming. I don't think that's actually quite right. He's not a charmer. But he's compelling and looks you in the eye. And he's full of stories. But he's excited. He's amped about everything. And he's this happy warrior type. There's this positivity about him.
他非常引人入胜。过去几个月里，我曾多次向朋友讲述这段经历，我觉得我一直在寻找合适的形容词。我觉得我想说他很有魅力，但我觉得这并不完全准确。他不是那种有魅力的人，但他引人注目，而且直视你的眼睛。他满肚子都是故事。但他很兴奋，对一切都感到兴奋。他属于那种“快乐的战士”类型。他身上有一种积极向上的特质。
So he sat down and he basically just started talking. And I took out my recorder and I recorded it. And he talked for about 90 minutes, and then it was over.
于是他坐下来，基本上就开始滔滔不绝。我拿出录音机，把这些录了下来。他讲了大约 90 分钟，然后就结束了。
You write that he had two pens clipped to his shirt collar?
你写道，他衬衫领子上别了两支笔？
That's true, yes.
那是真的，是的。
And you write, "over 90 minutes, he barely touched his food and never took off his coat"?
你还写道：“在 90 分钟里，他几乎没动过食物，也从没脱过外套”？
Correct. He really wasn't there for the meal. He was there to talk.
没错。他去那里真不是为了吃饭的，他是为了交谈。
You barely get a word in edgewise.
你几乎插不进话。
Correct. Yeah.
没错。是的。
Well, we try to make sure the content has the swagger to it. It has a point of view. People come up to me-- we always laugh. We'd say, you don't come to Breitbart for a pat on the head and a warm hug. You know you're coming here-- it's the fight club.
嗯，我们确保内容具有那种自信。它有自己的观点。人们来找我——我们总是笑。我们会说，你来布赖特巴特可不是为了讨个抚摸或得到一个温暖的拥抱。你知道你来这里是为了什么——这就是“搏击俱乐部”。
"We're the fight club." "You don't come here for a pat on the head and a warm hug. This isn't NPR."
“我们是搏击俱乐部。”“你来这里不是为了讨个抚摸或得到一个温暖的拥抱。这可不是 NPR (美国国家公共电台)。”
Yeah, I noticed he pointed that out. "This is not NPR." He said it more than once.
是的，我注意到他指出了这一点。“这可不是 NPR。”他不止一次这样说。
Yes.
是的。
We're not NPR. You're not going to come here and say, on this hand this--
我们不是 NPR。你不会来这里听到“一方面是这样……”
I think he was just so into the mission and so fired up about it.
我觉得他只是太专注于这项使命，对此太热衷了。
At the time, Bannon and Breitbart News were outsiders, waging an insurgent war against the Republican establishment, the mainstream media, President Obama. And Bannon gushed enthusiastically about the stories they were breaking, some of which did not seem true at all. Illegal immigrants sick with the Ebola virus crossing the border into Texas. An ISIS plot to kill the Pope. 10 counties in Texas that are controlled by the Mexican drug cartels.
当时，班农和布赖特巴特新闻是局外人，对共和党建制派、主流媒体和奥巴马总统发动了一场叛乱战争。班农热情洋溢地谈论着他们发布的独家新闻，其中一些看起来根本不是真的。例如非法移民带着埃博拉病毒跨越边境进入德克萨斯州，ISIS 策划暗杀教皇，德克萨斯州有 10 个县被墨西哥贩毒集团控制。
First off, there are 10 counties on the Rio Grande Valley that we do not have control of. When I say we do not have control of them, the cartels run them. McAllen, Texas.
首先，在格兰德河谷有 10 个县是我们无法控制的。当我说是无法控制时，是指贩毒集团在经营它们。德克萨斯州的麦卡伦。
And then he goes on to explain how McAllen is where all the drug lords have their grandmas and their moms. And they all have houses there.
然后他继续解释麦卡伦是所有毒枭的祖母和母亲居住的地方。他们都在那里有房子。
It's where all the cartels basically have a truce that that's where their mothers live. That's where the kids are going to school. They got the McAllen Medical Center. They all get their-- all the cartels, all the families of cartels are up in McAllen in broad daylight. It's like prohibition in the '20s. It's not that people-- remember the movie with Sean Connery in the thingamajig where he says, it's not that people don't know where the whiskey is. It's the political will to go beat down the door to get the whiskey.
基本上，所有贩毒集团都在那里达成了休战，那是他们的母亲居住的地方。那是孩子们上学的地方。他们有麦卡伦医疗中心。他们都在那里——所有的贩毒集团，所有贩毒集团的家属都在大白天待在麦卡伦。就像 20 年代的禁酒令时期。并不是说人们——记得肖恩·康纳利在那部电影里说的话吗？不是人们不知道威士忌在哪里，而是缺乏去踢开门取回威士忌的政治意愿。
I have to say, if this story isn't true, he is sure telling the hell out of it. He's going from this image of their moms are there and their kids are in school, and they're all in the same hospital. And then he goes to this movie reference. He is just pitching this so great.
我不得不说，即使这个故事不是真的，他讲得也真是精彩绝伦。他从毒枭的母亲和孩子都在同一个地方上学和就医的画面，引申到那部电影的桥段。他真的太会推销这个故事了。
Yeah. I'm smiling right now listening to it. He is telling the hell out of it, including flying over McAllen and you see a third of it looks like a slum town and a third of it is normal, but then a third of it, you could be flying over Bel-Air and there's swimming pools.
是的。我现在听着都在笑。他讲得真是太精彩了，包括飞越麦卡伦上空，你看到三分之一像贫民窟，三分之一很正常，但另外三分之一，你就像飞在贝莱尔上空，到处都是游泳池。
Everything's got a pool. It's got a Jaguar and a Mercedes dealer right there, cash only. I think it's the number one Jaguar place in the country.
到处都有游泳池。那里就有捷豹和梅赛德斯经销商，只收现金。我想那是全国最大的捷豹销售点。
Jaguar?
捷豹？
Right. How is he identifying cars from the air? Has he even flown over it, or is this all in his imagination? Also, that's what every place looks like when you fly over it. But in the moment, you're like, wow. And with something like this, it's just a story you can't check. How do you check without being a reporter on the ground who's deeply sourced? You really can't check whether all the cartel lords' grandmas go to the same hospital in McAllen.
没错。他是怎么在空中识别出汽车的？他真的飞越过那里吗？还是这全在他的想象中？而且，当你飞越任何地方时，看起来都是那样。但在那一刻，你会觉得“哇”。像这样的事情，你根本无法核实。如果你不是一名深耕当地且线人众多的记者，你该怎么核实？你真的无法证实所有毒枭的祖母是不是都在麦卡伦的同一家医院看病。
By the way, it is true that some cartel families live in McAllen. But this idea that they've declared some big truce or that law enforcement gives them a pass? That's embellishment. Reid wrote about all this recently in an article he did for VICE News. This is where he works these days. But his original story, the one he was writing for Rolling Stone back in 2014, never got published. He couldn't convince his editors to run it. The whole world of it-- Steve Bannon, Breitbart News-- it all seemed too fringy. Not important. These right-wing agitators with their far-out ideas.
顺便说一句，一些贩毒集团的家属住在麦卡伦确实是真的。但关于他们达成了某种大休战，或者执法部门对他们网开一面的想法？那是夸大其词。里德最近在为 VICE News 撰写的一篇文章中写到了这一切，那是他现在工作的地方。但他最初为《滚石》撰写的那篇 2014 年的文章从未发表。他说服不了他的编辑刊登它。这一切——史蒂夫·班农、布赖特巴特新闻——看起来太边缘化了。不重要。这些有着离奇想法的右翼煽动者。
And listen to what seemed completely irrelevant 2 and 1/2 years ago. For the story, Reid went to a party at Breitbart headquarters, a townhouse in Washington, DC, that Bannon called the Breitbart Embassy.
听听 2 年半前看起来完全无关紧要的事情。为了写那篇报道，里德去参加了布赖特巴特总部的一个派对，那是华盛顿特区的一栋联排别墅，班农称之为“布赖特巴特大使馆”。
It is a townhouse that looks like any other, really, but I saw some guys in khakis and blue blazers coming in and out with drinks in their hands. And I went in and there was this whole party going on inside. I didn't recognize a lot of people. I recognized Laura Ingraham, the radio host. I recognized Jeff Sessions because years earlier I'd worked in the Senate. And I thought, what is Jeff Sessions doing here?
那是一栋看起来和其他房子没什么两样的联排别墅，但我看到一些穿着卡其裤和蓝色西装外套的人手里拿着饮料进进出出。我走进去，里面正在举行一场派对。我不认识很多人。我认出了电台主持人劳拉·英格拉汉姆 (Laura Ingraham)。我认出了杰夫·塞申斯 (Jeff Sessions)，因为几年前我在参议院工作过。我心想，杰夫·塞申斯在这里做什么？
Jeff Sessions, of course, an early Trump supporter, now Attorney General of the United States.
杰夫·塞申斯当然是特朗普的早期支持者，现在是美国司法部长。
I remember Jeff Sessions being just the most marginal member of the Senate that there could be. Just an older white guy from Alabama with totally unsurprising positions. And Sessions did not look super comfortable. Everyone at the party was pretty young, by and large. He was there. He looked kind of out of place. And I just thought, why is he here?
我记得杰夫·塞申斯是参议院里最边缘的成员之一。只是一个来自阿拉巴马州、立场完全平平无奇的老白人男性。塞申斯看起来不太自在。派对上的人基本上都很年轻。他在那里，看起来有点格格不入。我只是在想，他为什么在这里？
In fact, he and Bannon, and his staff and the Breitbart staff knew each other. Reid asked Sessions a question or two for his story just to be polite, and Sessions answered. Praised Breitbart. Said how influential it was with his constituents, which Reid assumed was just a courtesy to his host. Reid headed out to the backyard.
事实上，他和班农，还有他的员工以及布赖特巴特的员工都认识。为了礼貌起见，里德问了塞申斯一两个问题，塞申斯回答了，还称赞了布赖特巴特。他说布赖特巴特对他的选民非常有影响力，里德认为这只是对东道主的客套。里德走到了后院。
Talking to some of the Breitbart writers who were smoking cigarettes with Nigel Farage, head of the UK Independence Party, who was telling me about leaving the European Union, which I didn't think sounded particularly likely. It felt like outcasts.
和一些正在与英国独立党领袖奈杰尔·法拉奇 (Nigel Farage) 抽烟的布赖特巴特撰稿人交谈，法拉奇正在告诉我关于离开欧盟的事，我觉得这听起来不太可能。感觉他们就像是一群被遗忘的人。
At dinner, Reid was sitting next to a fellow named Sebastian Gorka, who seemed full of big ideas, but nice enough. Today, he's a deputy assistant to the president.
在晚餐时，里德坐在一个名叫塞巴斯蒂安·戈尔卡 (Sebastian Gorka) 的人旁边，他似乎有很多宏大的想法，但人还不错。今天，他是总统的副助理。
He seemed familiar in this college Republican kind of way, which is that I remember, as a college student, there being a small but vocal and proudly uninterested group of campus conservatives who didn't want to hang out with anyone else and who wore bow ties around and whose whole unifying theory was that they understood the truth about the world and no one else did. That was the vibe I got at the party.
他那种大学共和党人的样子让我觉得很熟悉，也就是我记得作为一名大学生时，校园里有一群人数虽少但言辞激烈且自视甚高的保守派，他们不想和其他人交往，穿着领结，统一的理论就是他们理解关于这个世界的真相而其他人都不理解。这就是我在派对上感受到的氛围。
Back in the beginning of this year, when Reid went through his old notes again about the party and the Odeon and wrote up a story for VICE, Gorka did not seem significant. He didn't include him in the story.
今年年初，当里德重新翻看关于那次派对和 Odeon 的旧笔记并为 VICE 写报道时，戈尔卡似乎并不重要，他没有把戈尔卡写进去。
Since then, it's been this sort of emergence of Sebastian Gorka in the White House, which has got me thinking, who else was at this party? Who else was hanging out with these guys all the time? And if Sessions was there, I'm sure it was a good bet that Stephen Miller was there.
从那以后，塞巴斯蒂安·戈尔卡在白宫的这种崛起让我开始思考，还有谁参加了那次派对？还有谁一直和这些人混在一起？如果塞申斯在那儿，我敢打赌史蒂芬·米勒 (Stephen Miller) 肯定也在。
Stephen Miller, former Sessions staffer, now senior adviser in charge of domestic policy for the president, who co-wrote President Trump's inaugural address with Steve Bannon.
史蒂芬·米勒，前塞申斯的工作人员，现在是负责总统国内政策的高级顾问，曾与史蒂夫·班农共同撰写了特朗普总统的就职演说。
And at the time, if you'd said, this room is full of the most important future policy thinkers in America, it just would have been so implausible because they were so fringe.
而在当时，如果你说这个房间里满是美国未来最重要的政策思想家，这会显得非常难以置信，因为他们当时太边缘化了。
How did we get to now, with a president who proudly sees himself as a disruptive force, who's out to undo decades of bipartisan policy? Well, part of the story really starts with the people at that party, who were championing economic nationalism, who wanted to curtail illegal and legal immigration, renegotiate trade deals. The beginning of now happened in 2014 with them.
我们是如何走到今天这一步的，总统以破坏者的身份自居，决心推翻数十年的两党政策？这个故事其实始于那场派对上的人，他们支持经济民族主义，想要限制非法和合法移民，重新谈判贸易协定。现在的开端发生在 2014 年，和他们有关。
Today on our program, we have the story of the people at that party at the Breitbart Embassy and how, before Donald Trump even announced his candidacy, they took their ideas out for a test run with the voters in a congressional race in Virginia. What they learned and how it got us to today. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目讲述了在那场“布赖特巴特大使馆”派对上的人们的故事，以及在唐纳德·特朗普宣布竞选之前，他们是如何在弗吉尼亚州的一场国会竞选中通过选民对他们的想法进行试验的。他们学到了什么，以及它是如何带我们走到今天的。来自芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，这是《这就是美国生活》(This American Life)。请留下来。
Act One, The Brat Pack.
第一幕：小屁孩帮 (The Brat Pack)。
So obviously, one of the main issues that Donald Trump campaigned on and won on was immigration. Fewer immigrants, essentially, was the idea, as well as a crackdown on anybody who's in the country illegally. But it's interesting to remember that, back in 2014, just two years before Trump became president, the Republican Party was heading in the exact opposite direction. And you can hear it in the way this particular congressman, Congressman Mulvaney of South Carolina, opened this Republican breakfast meeting in his district back then. Mulvaney rode the Tea Party wave into office in 2010. Super conservative Tea Partier. Didn't support John Boehner for the speakership because Boehner worked too closely with Obama. Very conservative guy.
很显然，唐纳德·特朗普竞选并获胜的主要议题之一是移民。基本想法是减少移民，并对任何非法居留该国的人进行打击。但有趣的是，在特朗普成为总统之前的 2014 年，共和党正朝着完全相反的方向发展。你可以从当时南卡罗来纳州的国会议员穆尔瓦尼 (Mulvaney) 在他选区的共和党早餐会上开场的话中听出来。穆尔瓦尼在 2010 年乘着茶党浪潮进入政界。超级保守的茶党成员。不支持约翰·博纳 (John Boehner) 担任议长，因为博纳与奥巴马合作太紧密。非常保守的家伙。
I want to talk about something that we don't talk about much in the Republican Party, which is fruit. I would like to talk about fruit, because I got a piece of fruit on my desk about a year ago. An unusual piece of fruit-- not something you ordinarily get from South Carolina. We get peaches on our desk all the time. But about a year ago, I got a piece of fruit on my desk. It was a cantaloupe.
我想谈谈我们在共和党内部不太谈论的一件事，那就是水果。我想谈谈水果，因为大约一年前，我的办公桌上放了一件水果。一件不寻常的水果——不是那种你在南卡罗来纳州通常会收到的东西。我们的办公桌上总是放着桃子。但大约一年前，我的桌上收到了一个哈密瓜。
A cantaloupe. Mick Mulvaney got a cantaloupe on his desk right after another member of the Republican Party, Trey Gowdy, had been talking about the children of undocumented immigrants. Dreamers who, he said, sometimes are really successful. Valedictorians of their classes.
一个哈密瓜。米克·穆尔瓦尼在共和党另一位成员特雷·高迪 (Trey Gowdy) 谈论无证移民的孩子后，桌上就放了一个哈密瓜。高迪说，梦想生有时非常成功。他们是班级的毕业生代表。
And was interrupted by another member of my party who said, Trey, you know, that's exactly right. But for every one of those who is a valedictorian in their party, there are a hundred of them with calves the size of cantaloupes, carrying 75-pound bags of marijuana across the southwestern border. Every single Republican member of Congress got a cantaloupe on their desk within 24 hours.
然后被我们党内另一位成员打断了，他说：“特雷，你知道，这完全正确。但每一位毕业生代表，背后就有一百个小腿像哈密瓜一样大的人，扛着 75 磅重的大麻袋穿越西南边境。”24 小时内，每一位共和党国会议员的桌上都收到了一个哈密瓜。
These came from activists who wanted the Dreamers to stay in the United States. They left a cantaloupe on the desk of most congressional Republicans to send a message about how out of touch their party was around the issue of immigration. This audio, by the way, is from a documentary on Frontline called Immigration Battle.
这些来自希望梦想生留在美国的活动人士。他们在大多数共和党国会议员的桌上留下了一个哈密瓜，以传达关于他们的党在移民问题上是多么脱节的信息。顺便说一下，这段音频来自《前线》纪录片《移民之战》。
Think about whether or not that person is ever, ever going to consider voting for a Republican candidate ever again. At some point, we're going to have to figure out that, if you take the entire African-American community and write them off, take the entire Hispanic community and write them off, take the entire gay community and write them off, what's left? About 38% of the country. You cannot win with 38% of the country. We have to figure out how to deal with it as a party. We're losing too many elections. We're writing off too many people.
想想那个人是否还会考虑再给共和党候选人投票。在某个时候，我们得搞清楚，如果你把整个非裔美国人社区写掉，把整个西班牙裔社区写掉，把整个同性恋社区写掉，还剩下什么？大约全国 38% 的人。你不能用全国 38% 的支持率赢得选举。我们必须弄清楚如何作为一个政党来处理这个问题。我们输掉了太多的选举。我们放弃了太多的人。
In 2014, Mick Mulvaney supported an immigration reform deal, including a path to legal status for undocumented immigrants. And at the time, which you can tell from that quote, it seemed like good politics. If you remember right after Mitt Romney lost the 2012 campaign, the Republican Party, led by party chairman at the time Reince Priebus, commissioned this autopsy report. What did we do wrong? How do we start winning elections again?
2014 年，米克·穆尔瓦尼支持一项移民改革协议，包括为无证移民提供合法身份的途径。在当时，你可以从那句引言中看出，这看起来是好的政治策略。如果你还记得米特·罗姆尼 (Mitt Romney) 在 2012 年竞选失利后，由时任共和党主席赖因斯·普利巴斯 (Reince Priebus) 领导的共和党委托撰写的那份尸检报告。我们做错了什么？我们如何才能再次赢得选举？
And one of the big take-homes of that report was this sentence-- "If Hispanic-Americans perceive that a GOP nominee or candidate does not want them in the United States, they will not pay attention to our next sentence."
那份报告的一大收获就是这句话——“如果西班牙裔美国人认为共和党提名人或候选人不想让他们留在美国，他们就不会再听我们的下一句话。”
Things have changed in two years, huh? Today, both Mick Mulvaney and Reince Priebus work for this guy.
两年过去了，情况变了，对吧？今天，米克·穆尔瓦尼和赖因斯·普利巴斯都在为这个人工作。
When politicians talk about immigration reform, they usually mean the following-- amnesty, open borders, lower wages. Anyone who has entered the United States illegally is subject to deportation. That is what it means to have laws and to have a country. Otherwise, we don't have a country.
当政客们谈论移民改革时，他们通常指的是：大赦、开放边境、降低工资。任何非法进入美国的人都应被驱逐出境。这就是拥有法律和国家意味着什么。否则，我们就没有国家。
So how did the Republican Party reverse itself so fully so quickly on immigration? And why? Well, that is the thing we want to talk about today. That's the thing that happened in 2014, before Trump started running back at the beginning of now-- around the same time as that Breitbart Embassy party. People at that very party made immigration an issue in this one congressional race that we want to tell you about, and it demonstrated the power of that issue of immigration and showed how somebody might use it to win the presidency.
那么共和党是如何在移民问题上如此迅速地完全逆转的？为什么？嗯，这就是我们今天想谈的事情。这就是 2014 年发生的事情，在特朗普开始竞选之前，在现在开端的时候——大约和那场“布赖特巴特大使馆”派对在同一时间。那场派对上的人们让移民问题成为了我们想向你们介绍的那场国会竞选中的议题，这展示了移民议题的力量，也展示了某人如何利用它来赢得总统职位。
And interestingly, this particular congressional race started off not having much to do with immigration. Zoe Chace explains.
有趣的是，这场特定的国会竞选起初与移民关系不大。佐伊·蔡斯 (Zoe Chace) 解释道。
You could pick a few places to begin the story of this congressional race, but I'm going to start off on the top of this mountain in Virginia. Ron Maxwell lives up here. He's a movie director.
你可以挑选几个地方来开始这场国会竞选的故事，但我打算从弗吉尼亚州的这座山顶开始。罗恩·麦克斯韦 (Ron Maxwell) 住在山上。他是一位电影导演。
1,450 feet above sea level. Hi.
海拔 1450 英尺。你好。
Hey. I'm Zoe.
嘿，我是佐伊。
Welcome.
欢迎。
Thanks.
谢谢。
He did the movie Gettysburg 25 years ago. He's a Hollywood guy in the middle of the woods. One of those conservatives who knows a ton of other conservatives-- money people, media people. He's a connector. Good-natured, loud-mouth guy. Has lots of opinions, lots of history books in his study. He's an America First guy, like since way before now. He writes editorials railing at the government, has written a lot about his fear that Mexicans will reconquer the Southwest. But back in 2013, he was focused on something else.
他 25 年前拍了电影《葛底斯堡》。他是森林里的好莱坞人。他属于那种认识一大堆保守派的保守派——搞钱的、搞媒体的。他是连接者。性格随和，大嗓门。有很多观点，书房里有好多历史书。他是一个“美国优先”的人，早在现在之前就是了。他写社论抨击政府，写了很多关于他担心墨西哥人会重新征服西南部的文章。但在 2013 年，他专注于别的事情。
Here was the deal-breaker for me. In the summer of 2013, President Obama was seriously considering bombing Damascus.
这是我的底线。2013 年夏天，奥巴马总统正在认真考虑轰炸大马士革。
Ron was focused on keeping the US out of another war. That's a huge part of the America First idea, as you probably know-- staying out of international conflict. In the summer of 2013, President Assad had used chemical weapons on his people. The administration was calling on Congress to give him military authorization. Obama met with the two most important people in the House to get that done-- the Speaker of the House John Boehner, and House Majority Leader Eric Cantor, who was from Ron's state, Virginia. Ron was watching the news.
罗恩专注于让美国远离另一场战争。如你所知，“美国优先”理念的一个重要部分就是远离国际冲突。2013 年夏天，阿萨德总统对本国人民使用了化学武器。政府呼吁国会给予他军事授权。奥巴马会见了众议院最重要的两个人来实现这一目标——众议院议长约翰·博纳和众议院多数党领袖埃里克·坎托 (Eric Cantor)，他来自罗恩的州，弗吉尼亚州。罗恩正在看新闻。
And so he met with Boehner and Eric Cantor went to the White House to meet with him. And after the meeting, Boehner and Cantor stepped out and they said in a joint press conference right on the steps of the White House, we fully support President Obama in his desire to attack Damascus and depose, remove Assad from government. In other words, they were all in.
所以他会见了博纳，埃里克·坎托也去了白宫见他。会面后，博纳和坎托走出来，在白宫台阶上举行了一场联合新闻发布会，他们说，我们全力支持奥巴马总统进攻大马士革并罢免阿萨德政府的愿望。换句话说，他们全力以赴。
And I thought, did Eric Cantor consult with the people in his district [INAUDIBLE] we get involved in another Iraq? That's what it would have been. We would have been all in on another Iraq. That, Zoe, was the straw that broke my camel's back. I was like, I can no longer sit by. We're way past writing editorials. This guy needs to be removed from office.
我想，埃里克·坎托有没有征求他选区人民的意见？我们是不是要卷入另一场伊拉克战争？这就是当时的情况。我们将全力以赴投入另一场伊拉克战争。佐伊，那是我骆驼背上的最后一根稻草。我想，我再也不能袖手旁观了。我们早就过了写社论的时候了。这家伙必须被撤职。
This was a really crazy idea. Like, yeah, this is a democracy. Technically, you should be able to vote reps you don't like out of office. But not Eric Cantor. Not the House majority leader. He's got all the money in the world to run an election with. He's got the entire Republican Party behind him. He's an incumbent, obviously. In fact, it had never been done. Actually, in the history of the republic no one had voted out an incumbent House majority leader, a little-known but common-sense statistic.
这真是一个疯狂的想法。是的，这是一个民主国家。理论上，你应该能够通过投票把你讨厌的代表赶下台。但埃里克·坎托不行。不是众议院多数党领袖。他有全世界的钱来竞选。他有整个共和党在背后支持他。他显然是现任议员。事实上，这从未发生过。实际上，在共和国历史上，从来没有人投票罢免过现任的众议院多数党领袖，这是一个鲜为人知但常识性的统计数据。
I was given a lot of reasons to just not go there. But I was already convicted by that point. I was convicted this had to happen. So I made some calls down to Tea Party people that I didn't know. I made some phone calls. They said, well, call Larry Nordvig down-- his Tea Party in Richmond.
很多人劝我不要去碰这个。但我当时已经认定必须这么做。所以我给一些我不认识的茶党人打了电话。我说，“打给拉里·诺德维格 (Larry Nordvig)——他在里士满的茶党。”
Larry Nordvig had just become executive director of the Richmond Tea Party. Trim mustache, all business, looks like an airline pilot, which is what he was before he got political. Larry told Ron that, at their Tea Party meetings, he'd sensed some dissatisfaction with Eric Cantor.
拉里·诺德维格刚成为里士满茶党的执行董事。小胡子，做事干练，看起来像个航空公司飞行员，那正是他从政之前的工作。拉里告诉罗恩，在他们的茶党会议上，他感觉到人们对埃里克·坎托有些不满。
I think one of the first meetings, somebody in the back row raised their hand and they said, can you help us get rid of Eric Cantor? That was one of the very first things that happened. And I thought, wow, these people are serious.
我想在第一次会议上，后排有人举手说：“你能帮我们除掉埃里克·坎托吗？”那是发生的第一件事之一。我想，哇，这些人是认真的。
And I said, Larry, what's the lay of the land down there in his district? And he said, just, people are angry. They don't like him. They want him to go, so.
我说：“拉里，他选区里的情况如何？”他说：“人们很愤怒。他们不喜欢他。他们想让他走。”
Not about immigration. Not then.
当时还没谈到移民。
They were angry, principally, for the bailouts. Cronyism-- that's the issue. It boils down to cronyism. And the fact that he was never around. He never answered anybody's phone calls. He'd get letters like that.
他们愤怒主要是因为救助计划。裙带关系——那才是问题所在。归根结底就是裙带关系。而且他从不露面。他从不接听任何人的电话。他会收到那样的信。
Eric Cantor was taking them for granted, paying more attention to donors rather than voters, Larry says. And people just hated him. Again, Larry.
拉里说，埃里克·坎托理所当然地认为他很稳，比起选民，他更关注捐赠者。人们只是讨厌他。拉里再次说道：
I'm starting to get the feeling if we ran a hat rack with a hat on it, we could probably beat Eric Cantor.
我开始觉得如果我们推选一个挂着帽子的衣架，可能都能打败埃里克·坎托。
And they found a guy. A guy named Dave Brat. At first, he seemed only marginally better than a hat rack. Brat was an economics professor from a small liberal arts college, not a politician.
他们找到了一个人。一个名叫戴夫·布拉特 (Dave Brat) 的人。起初，他看起来只比衣架好那么一点点。布拉特是一所小型文理学院的经济学教授，不是政客。
Pros-- corn-fed, Midwestern, handsome, fan of Ayn Rand, practicing Christian, known within the Tea Party, friendly, not afraid of crowds the way Cantor seemed to be. He wanted to run, actually had been spurned by Cantor over a political post he wanted.
优点——玉米喂养的、中西部人、英俊、安·兰德的粉丝、虔诚的基督徒、在茶党内部有名、友好、不怕人群（不像坎托看起来那样）。他其实想竞选，实际上之前因为一个他想要的政治职位而被坎托拒绝过。
Cons-- very little campaign experience, no Beltway connections, few people knew who he was, no money whatsoever. Oh, and he talks like an economics professor.
缺点——竞选经验很少、没有华盛顿圈内人脉、没几个人知道他是谁、根本没有钱。哦，他说话就像个经济学教授。
So these three guys-- Larry with the mustache, Ron the movie guy, Brat the professor-- met at a Greek restaurant in Charlottesville to hash out their plan. It was emotionally real, Ron tells me. Intense male bonding. They felt very David and Goliath-y.
所以这三个人——留着小胡子的拉里、电影人罗恩、教授布拉特——在夏洛茨维尔的一家希腊餐馆碰面敲定计划。罗恩告诉我，那感觉真实且动人。强烈的男人间的纽带感。他们感觉自己非常像大卫对决歌利亚。
And the whole power structure, and the whole Republican Party of Virginia would come down like a ton of bricks on all of us.
整个权力结构，整个弗吉尼亚州共和党，都会像泰山压顶一样向我们袭来。
By the end, they had a deal. Dave Brat would be better than a hat rack. Larry would organize the grassroots. And Ron would call donors and his fellow populists in the media.
最终，他们达成了协议。戴夫·布拉特会比衣架好。拉里负责基层组织。罗恩则负责联络捐赠者和媒体界的民粹主义同僚。
So we ended that discussion that night by saying, if we're going to do this, nobody can change their mind. Because I said, Dave, you can't change your mind three months from now, because once I open my Rolodex, you can't pull the rug out from under me, because then people are going to say, what was that about? I said, already they're going to laugh at me. If I tell them we've got a candidate to run against Eric Cantor and I call my people, whether I'm asking for money or whether I'm asking for endorsements or whatever I'm asking for, their first instinct is they're going to laugh. And the second instinct is they're going to tell me to go away.
所以那天晚上结束讨论时，我说，如果我们要做这件事，谁都不能反悔。因为我说：“戴夫，你三个月后不能反悔，因为一旦我打开我的通讯录，你就不能拆我的台，因为那样别人会说，那是怎么回事？我已经说过了，他们会嘲笑我。如果我告诉他们我们有人选要挑战埃里克·坎托，无论我是要求捐款还是背书，他们的第一反应肯定是笑，第二反应就是让我滚。”
Ron didn't call his people right away. First, they wanted to get Brat off the ground. One of the first media appearances was local, and it was a good local story. Wonky random Virginian taking on one of the most powerful guys in Congress.
罗恩没有立即给他的圈内人打电话。首先，他们想让布拉特起步。最早的一次媒体露面是本地的，是一个不错的本地故事。一个古怪的弗吉尼亚人挑战国会最有权势的人之一。
Dr. David Brat, who is a well-known face here on NBC12. Someone we often use as an expert on economic issues in his capacity as a professor at Randolph-Macon. But today, Dr. Brat is here for a much different reason. He's ready to launch a primary challenge against Congressman Cantor. Dr. Brat, why are you doing this?
戴夫·布拉特博士，在 NBC12 是位熟面孔。他作为伦道夫-梅肯学院的教授，我们常请他作为经济问题专家出镜。但今天，布拉特博士来这里的原因大不相同。他准备发起针对坎托议员的初选挑战。布拉特博士，你为什么这么做？
Yeah. Well, you know I've been on over the past five or 10 years, and the campaign is all about economics. I think the people watching know the deficits and the debt is up to $17 trillion dollars. We have severe--
是的，你知道过去五到十年我一直都在出镜，竞选完全是关于经济。我想观众知道赤字和债务已经达到了 17 万亿美元。我们有严重的——
Economics. It's not the most electrifying pitch. It's not "Mexican rapists are swarming the border."
经济。这并不是最令人兴奋的卖点。这可不是“墨西哥强奸犯正蜂拥而至边境”。
Well, the key to what the leadership is doing-- they're not addressing the main issues that the people want addressed.
关键在于领导层正在做的事情——他们没有解决人们希望解决的主要议题。
To add to Brat's potential problems, Larry found a campaign manager with very little experience, just out of college, Zach Werrell, 22 years old. Zach, Larry, and Dave Brat met up at a Panera Bread for 45 minutes, and then Zach was hired.
雪上加霜的是，拉里找了一个几乎没有竞选经验的竞选经理，刚大学毕业的扎克·沃雷尔 (Zach Werrell)，22 岁。扎克、拉里和戴夫·布拉特在一家 Panera 面包店碰面了 45 分钟，扎克就被雇用了。
I don't know if there was anybody else going for that job, but two things helped me. I studied economics, so Dave and I were able to talk about stuff. And then, having gone to Haverford, he knew the school was good, and obviously I wasn't an idiot.
我不知道还有没有别人在争取这份工作，但有两件事帮了我。我学的是经济学，所以戴夫和我能谈得来。而且，我上了哈弗福德学院，他知道那所学校不错，显然我不是个傻瓜。
I talked to Zach on his parents' porch in this small riverside Maryland town. He remembers it was hard for the campaign to get attention.
我在他父母在马里兰州河边小镇的门廊上和扎克交谈。他记得竞选团队很难引起关注。
Almost nobody cared. It was hard to get media coverage of anything. We did a press conference in front of Cantor's office and nobody showed up, so we had all of our volunteers pull their phones out and pretend like we had a bunch of media there.
几乎没人关心。很难获得任何媒体报道。我们在坎托的办公室外开了个新闻发布会，没人来，所以我们让所有的志愿者掏出手机，假装我们有一大堆媒体在那儿。
By the way, Dave Brat and Eric Cantor both turned down my requests to interview them for this story.
顺便说一下，戴夫·布拉特和埃里克·坎托都拒绝了我的采访要求。
Brat's speeches always started the same way. He'd introduce himself, give some biography, then he'd go through something called the "Virginia Republican Creed," which has six principles. And he'd explain how Eric Cantor was not living up to each one of them.
布拉特的演讲总是以同样的方式开始。他会做自我介绍，讲讲生平，然后复述所谓的“弗吉尼亚共和党信条”，那有六条原则。然后他会解释埃里克·坎托是如何没能践行其中每一条的。
This nation was founded on probably three great strands. They all are interconnected. The Judeo-Christian tradition and the moral backdrop of that, the rule of law, and free market economics.
这个国家建立在可能三条伟大的主线上。它们都是相互关联的。犹太-基督教传统及其道德背景、法治和自由市场经济学。
Debt, Obamacare, and eventually he gets to immigration. And his big line about it involves crossing his arms to imitate supply and demand curves for labor and wages.
债务、奥巴马医改，最终他谈到了移民。关于移民的一大金句涉及他交叉双臂模仿劳动力和工资的供给与需求曲线。
Immigration was not the centerpiece of his campaign announcement.
移民并不是他竞选声明的核心。
Larry Nordvig, Tea Party guy, says that changed. And he remembers when. They were asking this big donor to give money to the campaign. They laid out three talking points they wanted to build the campaign around under the theme Washington, DC, is broken.
茶党人拉里·诺德维格说情况变了。他记得是在什么时候。当时他们正在请求一位大捐赠者给竞选捐款。他们提出了三个竞选核心议题，主题是“华盛顿特区已经坏了”。
And one of those three bullet points was immigration. And the particular person-- I'm not going to name that person-- the only thing that seemed to stick was the immigration bullet. That was the one that got his attention.
那三个要点中的一个就是移民。而那个特定的人——我就不点名了——唯一似乎起作用的就是移民那点。那是引起他注意的一点。
The magic word was amnesty. It cast a spell when you said it. Eric Cantor had said he supported a path to citizenship for children of undocumented immigrants. Remember, some kind of immigration reform bill was the party priority. The Reince Priebus report, the cantaloupe speech from Mulvaney. Cantor was on the same team. He was a party guy. To get Hispanic votes, Republicans needed to pass a bill. Kids shouldn't have to pay for the mistakes of their parents, he'd said. In other words, amnesty.
那个神奇的词是“大赦”。当你念出它时，就像施了咒语。埃里克·坎托曾表示他支持无证移民的孩子获得公民身份的途径。记住，某种移民改革法案是党的优先事项。普利巴斯的报告，穆尔瓦尼的哈密瓜演讲。坎托在同一个阵营。他是个典型的党内人士。为了获得西班牙裔的选票，共和党需要通过一项法案。他说过，孩子不应该为父母的错误付出代价。换句话说，就是大赦。
Amnesty was like waving a red flag in front of the crowd. And that donor that we had a meeting with, I know that word was, in particular, brought up during that conversation. Amnesty was seen as the ultimate in unfairness, if you will. Just ignoring the rule of law, which is important to Tea Party-type people. So you say the word amnesty in a speech and you got people's attention. And that was equally true of the media.
大赦就像在人群面前挥动红旗。而那个我们去开会的捐赠者，我知道那个词在谈话中被特别提到了。大赦被视为不公平的极致。仅仅忽视了法治，这对茶党型的人来说很重要。所以你在演讲中提到大赦，人们就会关注你。这对媒体来说也是同样真实的。
So they started to hit it, the little team working behind Brat. They started to notice every time they talked about amnesty, they'd get a reaction.
所以布拉特背后的团队开始攻击这一点。他们开始注意到，每次谈论大赦，他们都会得到某种反应。
As the campaign got rolling, the Hollywood connector Ron Maxwell decided to call Steve Bannon, who was running Breitbart News. They met at a film festival when Bannon had introduced a showing of Ron's movie. Ron talked to Steve Bannon, and shortly after that, Tea Party guy Larry ran into Bannon at a Tea Party celebration in DC.
竞选开始后，好莱坞连接者罗恩·麦克斯韦决定给经营布赖特巴特新闻的史蒂夫·班农打电话。他们在电影节上见过，当时班农介绍了罗恩的电影放映。罗恩和班农谈过之后不久，茶党人拉里在华盛顿的一次茶党庆祝活动中遇到了班农。
I saw Steve Bannon at that event. He had radio interviews going. And it was at that time he basically pointed to a reporter and said, hey, this gentleman here will help you out. Anytime you have anything from the campaign, then just tell it to him. So we kind of had an inroad there with Breitbart starting at the end of February, and it just grew.
我在那个活动上看到了史蒂夫·班农。他当时正在接受电台采访。就在那时，他基本上指着一名记者说：“嘿，这位先生会帮你的。任何时候竞选团队有什么消息，就告诉他。”所以我们在二月底就和布赖特巴特搭上了线，而且越走越近。
That was a style Bannon had. You could hear it on this weekly radio show he hosted for Breitbart. He's a good flack. A good publicist. He'll bring on politicians he agrees with and tell them on the air, anything you need, we're here for you. And he took up the Brat-Cantor race as one of Breitbart's crusades, with a very specific goal. He explained it to Reid Cherlin, actually, during that dinner interview you heard at the beginning of the show.
那是班农的风格。你可以在他为布赖特巴特主持的每周电台节目中听到。他是个出色的宣传员。他会邀请他认同的政客参加节目，然后在直播中告诉他们：“你们需要什么，我们都在这里支持你们。”他把布拉特挑战坎托的竞选作为布赖特巴特的十字军远征之一，并有着非常明确的目标。他其实向里德·切林解释过，就是节目开头你们听到的那次晚餐采访中。
We did not think Eric Cantor was going to be beaten.
我们没认为埃里克·坎托会被打败。
"We did not think Eric Cantor was going to be beaten," he says, but he thought they could get to at least 40% of the vote for Dave Brat.
“我们没认为埃里克·坎托会被打败，”他说，但他认为他们至少能让戴夫·布拉特获得 40% 的选票。
Our thesis was, anything with a 4 in front of it, amnesty's dead for the session.
我们的论点是，只要前面有个 4——大赦就在这次会期中终结了。
Our thesis was, anything with a 4 in it-- any percentage in the 40s-- amnesty's dead in this session of Congress, he says. Amnesty was Breitbart's word for any immigration reform deal making its way through Congress. His hope was, any chance for a bill would die because other Republicans in Congress would realize the House majority leader almost got ousted because of his support for immigration reform. So that was the goal. Scare Cantor and kill any potential bill.
我们的论点是，只要达到 40% 以上的百分比——大赦在这届国会中就死定了，他说。大赦是布赖特巴特对国会中任何移民改革法案的代称。他的希望是，任何法案夭折，因为国会里的其他共和党人会意识到众议院多数党领袖差点因为支持移民改革而下台。所以目标就是吓唬坎托，扼杀任何可能的法案。
Breitbart hammers Cantor and amnesty for months. Here are some headlines. "Cantor's 'Pledge' at Center of Secretive Immigration Push, Chairman Says," "Cantor Officially Backs Amnesty for DREAMers Who Enlist."
布赖特巴特数月来一直攻击坎托和大赦。以下是一些标题：“主席称坎托的‘承诺’处于秘密移民推动的中心”，“坎托正式支持为入伍的梦想生提供大赦”。
Matthew Boyle was one of the people writing these stories. I met up with him in DC. He's a total Washington type-- competitive politics reporter in a suit. I asked him, why go so hard on immigration? But he disagreed with the premise of the question. He said they were reading the electorate, calling the shots like they saw them.
马修·博伊尔 (Matthew Boyle) 是写这些报道的人之一。我在华盛顿见了他。他是一个典型的华盛顿人——穿着西装的竞选政治记者。我问他，为什么要死磕移民议题？但他不同意这个问题的前提。他说他们是在阅读选民，直言不讳。
We were just better journalists than the rest of the media. We were there ahead of everybody. We saw it months in advance. What we're doing is we're accurately reporting. We're reporting newsworthy, relevant, informative, and accurate and correct information about major political happenings in the United States. What's wrong with that? That's news. And we're better at it than anybody. Like, it's great.
我们只是比其他媒体更好的记者。我们走在每个人前面。我们提前几个月就看到了。我们所做的就是准确地报道。我们报道的是关于美国重大政治事件的具有新闻价值、相关、信息丰富且准确无误的信息。这有什么错？这就是新闻。而且我们比任何人都做得好。这太棒了。
Party leaders kept saying an immigration reform bill would save the Republican Party, but hating the bill was incredibly galvanizing for lots of the conservative media. Laura Ingraham, for example, hugely popular talk radio host-- also at that Breitbart party with Steve Bannon, by the way. She was constantly making the opposite argument from Republican leaders. She believed if undocumented immigrants got amnesty and then citizenship, they'd all become Democrats, dooming the Republican Party.
党内领导人一直说移民改革法案会拯救共和党，但憎恨该法案对很多保守派媒体来说极其具有煽动性。例如，极其受欢迎的电台主持人劳拉·英格拉汉姆——顺便说一下，她当时也在那场班农的派对上。她一直在发表与共和党领导人完全相反的观点。她认为如果无证移民获得大赦，然后获得公民身份，他们都会变成民主党人，使共和党陷入绝境。
Once Republicans sign on to some comprehensive immigration reform, it's pretty much over for them, because once formerly conservative states are turned reliably Democrat, you're never going to win the presidency again.
一旦共和党签署了某种全面的移民改革，他们基本就完了，因为一旦曾经保守的州变得铁杆支持民主党，你将永远无法再赢得总统大选。
Immigration was a good ground-game issue, too. Zach, the campaign manager, was collecting signatures to get Brat on the ballot. He'd hit the gun shows in Virginia.
移民也是一个很好的地面战议题。竞选经理扎克当时正在收集让布拉特进入选票的签名。他跑遍了弗吉尼亚州的枪支展览会。
You'd go there and be like, hi, we're running against Eric Cantor. Can you please sign our petition? People were like, no. Oh, the debt's really bad. We need to control the debt. I don't care. Do you agree Obamacare sucks? Yeah, but I'm not going to sign your thing. Will you help us get a guy on the ballot who's going to end illegal immigration? Oh, definitely. And that's what I just found. It was so easy.
你去那儿会说：“嘿，我们正在挑战埃里克·坎托。你能签个名吗？”人们会说：“不。哦，债务问题太严重了。我们需要控制债务。”“我不在乎。你同意奥巴马医改很烂吗？”“是的，但我不会签你的名。”“你能帮我们让一个会终止非法移民的人上选票吗？”“哦，当然可以。”这就是我发现的。太容易了。
The campaign and the national conservative media were starting to get on the same page. But they weren't really connected yet, besides a few articles in Breitbart and The Daily Caller. It was hard to get out the name of somebody nobody knew, which was Dave Brat.
竞选团队和国家保守派媒体开始达成一致。但除了布赖特巴特和《每日传讯》(The Daily Caller) 上的几篇文章外，他们还没有真正建立联系。很难让没几个人认识的某个人——也就是戴夫·布拉特——的名字传播开来。
One night, Zach and a couple volunteers were working late at the campaign office. They were listening to The Mark Levin Show, part of the same Rush/Laura Ingraham genre. He was yelling about amnesty. Here's Zach.
一天晚上，扎克和几个志愿者在竞选办公室加班。他们正在听马克·莱文 (Mark Levin) 的节目，属于拉什/劳拉·英格拉汉姆那种类型。他正在咆哮关于大赦的事。扎克说：
We were in the office late, listening to Mark Levin on like a Wednesday. I'm pretty sure that Mark was having one of those moments over immigration, I think.
我们在办公室待得很晚，周三晚上听马克·莱文的节目。我肯定当时马克正在移民问题上经历那一刻。
This is why they're never going to secure the border. We've already given amnesty. Now we have to secure the border. No, you don't, because there's always going to be new illegal aliens.
这就是为什么他们永远不会确保边境安全。我们已经给了大赦，现在我们必须确保边境安全。不，你们不用，因为总会有新的非法外来者。
He started going nuts on Cantor. He was just having one of those moments where he's about to have a stroke. And he's like, is anyone running against this guy? Please, somebody!
他开始针对坎托发疯。他只是处于那种快要中风的时刻。他说：“有人在挑战这个家伙吗？拜托，来个人吧！”
And Eric Cantor-- who's running against Eric Cantor in the Republican primary? Let's find out, Mr. Producer. I'm sure that it will be almost impossible to beat Cantor, but I'm going to endorse this guy and bring him on. This Cantor is the worst. He's worse than Boehner.
“埃里克·坎托——谁在共和党初选中挑战埃里克·坎托？让我们查查，制片人。我相信要打败坎托几乎是不可能的，但我会支持这家伙并请他上节目。这个坎托是最烂的。他比博纳还烂。”
And I'm like, oh, my god. So we called. I just had everybody in the office stop making volunteer calls and I was like, call the studio. Call the studio. Who all started dialing the studio for like 30 minutes, trying to get through. And then I actually got through, and I was like, Call Screener, there's somebody running against Cantor and I'm running his campaign. And they're like, oh, my god. Let's get him on.
我心想：“天哪。”所以我们打了电话。我让办公室里所有志愿者停止拨打捐款电话，说：“打给演播室！打给演播室！”所有人都开始拨打演播室电话，持续了约 30 分钟，试图打进去。然后我真的打进去了，我说：“筛选员，有人在挑战坎托，我正在负责他的竞选。”他们说：“天哪，让他上节目吧。”
And we got scheduled for like 8:45, the last 15 minutes of his show, on Friday night. So that's like the worst possible 15 minutes in talk radio. And Dave went on.
我们被安排在周五晚上 8 点 45 分，也就是他节目的最后 15 分钟。那是广播谈话节目中最糟糕的 15 分钟。戴夫上场了。
Because he's running in the Republican primary against Forrest Gump, a.k.a. Eric Cantor.
因为他正在共和党初选中挑战“阿甘”——也就是埃里克·坎托。
A Mark Levin fan told me that Mark's always called Eric Cantor Forrest Gump because of the way he talks.
一位马克·莱文的粉丝告诉我，马克一直称埃里克·坎托为阿甘，因为他说话的方式。
Now, Mr. Brat, you don't have to call him that. I call him that because that's who he reminds me of. But I understand that you have a PhD in economics. Is that correct?
现在，布拉特先生，你不必这样称呼他。我这样称呼他因为他让我想起了那个人。但我听说你有经济学博士学位，是真的吗？
Yeah, that's correct, Mark. Thanks for having me on. I got a master's in divinity from Princeton Theological Seminary before that, as well.
是的，是真的，马克。谢谢你邀请我。在那之前我还在普林斯顿神学院获得了神学硕士学位。
And we raised like $25,000 that night. OK. People are paying attention. And I'll tell you, the thing that got us a lot of the media attention and helped put gas in the tank in the form of donations from around the country was the immigration thing. We'd pitch them the same-- Cantor's been bad on this, this, and this, and they'd go, oh, that. That one of those thises is what we want to talk about.
那天晚上我们就筹到了大约 25000 美元。好吧，人们在注意了。而且我告诉你，让我们获得大量媒体关注并以全国捐款形式为竞选注入燃料的事情就是移民问题。我们向他们推销同样的东西——坎托在这一块、那一块都很糟糕，他们会说：“哦，那个。”那些议题中的一个就是我们想要谈论的。
Amnesty.
大赦。
Yeah. And so that's what we harped on him for.
是的。所以这就是我们死磕他的地方。
The campaign really needed this kind of attention because they had so little money to pay for advertising. Brat started showing up on the radio much more. Laura Ingraham framed his campaign very clearly.
竞选确实需要这种关注，因为他们几乎没钱支付广告费。布拉特开始更多地出现在电台节目中。劳拉·英格拉汉姆非常清晰地包装了他的竞选。
Eric Cantor has expressed his unending sympathy for people who've come here illegally. He claims we have a worker shortage in the United States. These moronic Republicans who continue to latch on to this issue as if the magic illegal immigrant is the elixir for all of our problems. They're going to solve everything because basically they're better than the native-born people.
埃里克·坎托对非法来到这里的人表示了无限的同情。他声称我们美国有劳动力短缺。这些愚蠢的共和党人继续纠缠在这个问题上，好像神奇的非法移民是解决我们所有问题的灵丹妙药。他们要解决一切，因为基本上他们比本土出生的人更好。
Joining us now, the man who wants to change all this. Dave Brat challenging Eric Cantor, the current House majority leader. Don't be a brat, Dave. How are you? Good to talk to you.
加入我们现在的嘉宾，那个想改变这一切的人。戴夫·布拉特，挑战现任众议院多数党领袖埃里克·坎托。别太傲慢，戴夫。你好吗？很高兴和你交谈。
Doing great, Laura. Thanks for having me on.
很好，劳拉。谢谢你邀请我。
Laura Ingraham straight-up endorsed Brat. She did a fundraiser for him. Ron Maxwell, Hollywood superconnector rich guy, had called Laura Ingraham early on. And he tells me he noticed when the Brat campaign really started to pick up speed-- end of May, 2014, when there was that increase of young kids coming across the border, fleeing gangs in El Salvador and Guatemala.
劳拉·英格拉汉姆直接背书了布拉特。她为他举办了一场筹款会。好莱坞超级连接者、富豪罗恩·麦克斯韦很早就给劳拉·英格拉汉姆打过电话。他告诉我，他注意到布拉特竞选真正开始加速的时候——2014 年 5 月底，当时有大量年轻孩子越过边境，逃离萨尔瓦多和危地马拉的帮派。
And there was a huge surge of people, and so that was in the news every day. And then it was all, Dave Brat is running against Eric Cantor on this issue. And he'd talk about it. He's saying, you see? There's no control at the border. You guys aren't doing anything about it. Look at this humanitarian crisis we have. All these kids running the gauntlet of coyotes and rape trees and blah, blah, blah, and all that stuff. Then he got more national attention.
人们大量涌入，所以那每天都在新闻里。然后全是关于“戴夫·布拉特正在就这个问题挑战埃里克·坎托”。他会谈论它。他说：“看到了吗？边境根本没有控制。你们什么都没做。看看我们面临的这种人道主义危机。所有这些孩子在穿越土狼、强奸树等等等等重重关卡……”然后他获得了更多的全国性关注。
Rape trees were something Breitbart Texas was writing about a lot in 2014. Trees ominously hung with girls' underwear apparently found along the border. It was not Brat's style to talk about rape trees. He talked about the crisis at the border in his own dense, numbery way.
强奸树是布赖特巴特德州分社在 2014 年写了很多关于它的东西。那是沿边境发现的挂着女孩内衣的阴森森的树。这不是布拉特的风格，他不谈强奸树。他用他那种密集、数字化的方式谈论边境危机。
The Washington Post reported-- Washington Times, sorry-- yesterday, 60,000 kids are expected to cross the border. $225 a day per child. And big business gets the cheap labor. That's what they want. But who's paying the $225 a day per 6,000 kids that are coming over the border with no parents--
《华盛顿邮报》报道——抱歉，是《华盛顿时报》，昨天报道说，预计有 6 万名孩子要越过边境。每个孩子每天 225 美元。而大企业得到了廉价劳动力。这就是他们想要的。但谁在支付这 6000 名没有父母的孩子越过边境每天 225 美元的费用——
60,000.
6 万。
--in what some are calling a humanitarian crisis because Eric Cantor is sending all the wrong signals.
——在某些人称之为人道主义危机的地方，因为埃里克·坎托发出了所有错误的信号。
At this point, things were heating up in Congress around an immigration reform bill, which included a path to legal status. Democratic Representative Luis Gutierrez was doing this countdown until the July 4 recess on the floor of the House every day. You've got 20 days to introduce immigration reform, et cetera. He and some Republicans were working together behind closed doors, trying to get enough votes to pass it. This was the bill that Steve Bannon had said Breitbart was expressly trying to kill.
此时，国会围绕移民改革法案的情况正在升温，包括通往合法身份的途径。民主党议员路易斯·古铁雷斯 (Luis Gutierrez) 每天都在众议院会议厅进行这种距离 7 月 4 日休会日的倒计时。他说“你还有 20 天时间来提出移民改革法案”等等。他和一些共和党人在闭门合作，试图获得足够的选票来通过它。这就是史蒂夫·班农所说的布赖特巴特明摆着要扼杀的法案。
Eric Cantor, at this point, had seemingly pulled to the right. He opposed a bill that offered citizenship to undocumented immigrants who enlisted in the military and then sent out these mailers to constituents like, I killed amnesty for illegal aliens. Gutierrez then planned a rally in Richmond about a week before the primary election to pressure Cantor to lead the house towards a vote on an immigration bill. Then radio host Laura Ingraham's people called the Brat campaign, said, you'd better be there, too. So Dave Brat showed up to hammer Cantor on amnesty.
埃里克·坎托此时似乎已经向右转了。他反对一项为入伍无证移民提供公民身份的法案，然后向选民发送了这些邮件，比如“我扼杀了非法外国人的大赦”。古铁雷斯随后计划在初选前一周左右在里士满举行集会，向坎托施压，要求他带领众议院投票通过移民法案。然后电台主持人劳拉·英格拉汉姆的人打电话给布拉特竞选团队，说：“你们最好也在那儿。”所以戴夫·布拉特出现了，就大赦问题猛烈抨击坎托。
There is no Republican in the country who is more liberal on immigration than Eric Cantor. This race comes down to the defining issue of our time. Virginia is ground zero in the fight to protect American workers. If we want to stop amnesty, then we must stop Eric Cantor on this election day, June 10.
全国没有一个共和党人在移民问题上比埃里克·坎托更自由派。这场竞选归结为我们这个时代决定性的问题。弗吉尼亚州是保护美国工人的斗争中心。如果我们想阻止大赦，那么我们必须在 6 月 10 日投票日阻止埃里克·坎托。
Zach, the campaign manager, remembers that Laura Ingraham's producer wrote the speech that Dave's reading here.
竞选经理扎克记得戴夫在这里念的演讲稿大半是劳拉·英格拉汉姆的制片人写的。
Yeah, I think the speech Dave read was largely written by Laura's people.
是的，我觉得戴夫读的那篇演讲大半是劳拉的人写的。
That explains a lot, because the way he sounds when he's reading it is maybe the way that she might talk instead of the way that he would talk.
这就解释得通了，因为他读的时候听起来可能更像是她会说的话，而不是他平时会说的。
Eric Cantor saying he opposes amnesty is like Barack Obama saying he opposes Obamacare.
埃里克·坎托声称反对大赦，就像奥巴马声称反对奥巴马医改一样。
Exactly. Dave would give a speech about long-term trends in productivity and wage rates in the United States since 1930 and how there's a market inflection point in 2008, and then she'd be like, oh, my god, Dave. I love economics, but I don't even know what the hell you're talking about.
正是如此。戴夫会发表关于 1930 年以来美国生产力和工资率的长期趋势、以及 2008 年市场拐点的演讲，然后她会说：“天哪，戴夫，我喜欢经济学，但我根本不知道你在鬼扯什么。”
I find it remarkable that Ingraham's people were helping out to this degree. She's a radio host. But her producer, Julia Hahn, was really intense about the issue of immigration. Her name came up whenever I asked about media on the Brat campaign. Zach says he thinks it was Julia who wrote the speech. I couldn't confirm that with Julia.
我发现英格拉汉姆的人竟然在如此程度上提供帮助，真是了不起。她是个电台主持人。但她的制片人朱莉娅·哈恩 (Julia Hahn) 对移民问题非常痴迷。每当我问起布拉特竞选团队的媒体事宜时，她的名字就会出现。扎克说他认为是朱莉娅写的演讲稿。我没法从朱莉娅那里核实这一点。
A year later, she was hired by Breitbart to write about immigration. She still works for Steve Bannon, in the White House now.
一年后，她被布赖特巴特聘用专门报道移民问题。她现在依然为史蒂夫·班农工作，就在白宫。
At this point, it shouldn't be a surprise to you what happened on election night. But at the time, it surprised a lot of people.
此时，选举之夜发生了什么对你来说应该不奇怪了。但在当时，它让很多人感到惊讶。
Begin, though, with major political upset for one of the most powerful Republicans in the country, Eric Cantor.
然而，先来看看这位全国最有权势的共和党人之一，埃里克·坎托的重大政治挫败。
Eric Cantor is out of Congress.
埃里克·坎托离开了国会。
--defeated by this Washington outsider and Tea Party candidate, Dave Brat.
——被这位华盛顿局外人和茶党候选人戴夫·布拉特击败。
Cantor lost by double digits. He'd spent $5 and 1/2 million. Brat had spent $200,000. You now know-- because of that whole Hillary Clinton thing-- but seriously, money does not buy election results. John Boehner cried, it was widely reported.
坎托以两位数的差距落败。他花了 550 万美元。布拉特只花了 20 万美元。你们现在知道了——因为希拉里·克林顿那档子事——但说真的，钱买不到选举结果。据广泛报道，约翰·博纳哭了。
When the results came in early, like by 7:45 that night, that Cantor was out and Dave Brat had won, Zach hadn't figured out what to say to the press when they actually won.
当结果在当晚 7 点 45 分左右早早出来，坎托出局、戴夫·布拉特获胜时，扎克还没想好真的赢了之后该对媒体说什么。
I was on the phone with CNN and I just was incapable of forming a coherent sentence. I was just so overwhelmed. I was exhausted. I wasn't crying or anything, but I was just so overcome with emotion. I was just like, [BABBLING].
我当时在和 CNN 通话，完全无法组织一句连贯的话。我太不知所措了。我筋疲力尽。我没有哭什么的，但我被情绪完全淹没了。我当时只是在[胡言乱语]。
The conservative media professionals, though, they knew exactly how to explain it. Here's Laura Ingraham with Megyn Kelly on Fox.
然而，保守派媒体专业人士知道该如何解释。这是劳拉·英格拉汉姆在福克斯频道与梅根·凯利 (Megyn Kelly) 的对话。
This is a massive wake-up call to the Republican Party if they choose to actually wake up at this point. If they don't-- if John Boehner and Paul Ryan and the rest of the crew in the GOP establishment move forward after this race, with this idea of, quote, "immigration reform," which is a pathway to some type of amnesty, eventually, they will put a wedge down the middle of the Republican Party that will, in my mind, prevent a Republican from winning in 2016, exactly the opposite of what they're contending. So this is an amazing moment for the people. It is not to be discounted as something that happened on a rainy day.
如果共和党选择在这一点上真正醒悟，这对他们是一个巨大的警钟。如果他们不醒悟——如果约翰·博纳、保罗·瑞安 (Paul Ryan) 和 GOP 建制派的其他人在这次竞选后继续推进这种想法——所谓的“移民改革”，也就是某种形式的大赦途径，最终，他们会在共和党内部划出一道鸿沟，在我看来，这将阻止共和党人在 2016 年获胜，这与他们所争论的恰恰相反。所以这对人民来说是一个惊人的时刻。不要把它仅仅看作是发生在雨天的一件小事。
As Breitbart said the next day, "Eric Cantor loses referendum on amnesty." Dave Brat won because of immigration. The rest of the media, the networks, and the big newspapers hadn't been reporting on the race very much before this. They didn't see Brat as a serious threat to Eric Cantor. But now that Brat won in a huge upset, they picked up on the conservative media's explanation for why it happened. That it was all about immigration, ignoring all the other issues, starting with Syria, the national debt, people personally offended by Cantor, people feeling ignored by Cantor. Here's ABC.
正如布赖特巴特第二天所说的：“埃里克·坎托输掉了关于大赦的公投。”戴夫·布拉特因为移民问题获胜。其余媒体、电视网和各大报纸在此之前并没有太多报道这场竞选。他们没把布拉特视为对坎托的严重威胁。但既然布拉特意外大获全胜，他们就采纳了保守派媒体对发生原因的解释，即这一切都是关于移民，忽略了所有其他问题，从叙利亚、国债到个人被坎托冒犯的人、感到被坎托忽视的人。这是 ABC 的报道。
Why did he lose? The big issue was immigration.
他为什么输了？大议题是移民。
CNN.
CNN 的报道。
That was the central issue here, that he was insufficiently tough when it came to the immigration issue.
这是这里的核心议题，他在移民问题上不够强硬。
That was the story. And as a result of this race and the coverage of this race, any immigration reform bill was doomed. Here's the Washington Post's Robert Costa on CBS.
故事就是这样。而由于这场竞选以及对这场竞选的报道，任何移民改革法案都注定失败了。《华盛顿邮报》的罗伯特·科斯塔 (Robert Costa) 在 CBS 上说道。
I stayed outside of the Republican Study Committee's Wednesday meeting at the Capitol, and every single member I asked on the conservative side of things said no chance for immigration this year.
我守在共和党研究委员会周三在国会的会议外，我问过的每一个保守派成员都说今年移民法案没机会了。
Back in Virginia, the Tea Party organizers resented the idea that it was immigration that had put Cantor out. Brat's campaign manager, Zach, says what the race was really about was that Cantor was ignoring his own district.
回到弗吉尼亚州，茶党组织者对“移民问题把坎托拉下马”的说法感到不满。布拉特的竞选经理扎克说，这场竞选真正的主题是坎托无视他自己的选区。
Laura Ingraham and others-- I'm not denigrating them at all or anything with this statement. But a lot of people would say Dave Brat won because of illegal immigration and that validates everything we're doing. I don't know-- I disagree with that. I think that immigration definitely played a big role in getting attention and money and national focus, but I think that, at the end of the day, it was Cantor's aloof and people saw him as a jerk.
劳拉·英格拉汉姆和其他人——我发表这个声明并没有贬低他们的意思。但很多人会说戴夫·布拉特获胜是因为非法移民，这验证了我们在做的一切。我不知道——我不同意这一点。我认为移民确实在吸引关注、金钱和全国焦点方面发挥了重要作用，但我认为，归根结底，是坎托表现得冷漠，人们视他为混蛋。
There were no exit polls. There was a poll, though, a week before the election of registered Republican primary voters in this district. Illegal immigration was fourth on the list of important issues to these voters, way below Obamacare.
没有出口民调。不过，选举前一周在这个选区对注册共和党初选选民进行过民意调查。非法移民在这些选民的重要议题列表中排名第四，远低于奥巴马医改。
There was also a poll a week after the election after all the media coverage, where half the voters said immigration was a significant reason for their vote, and half said it wasn't. Only 12% said immigration was the main reason they voted for him.
在媒体报道之后，选举后一周也有一个民意调查，一半的选民说移民是他们投票的重要原因，另一半则说不是。只有 12% 的人说移民是他们投票给他的主要原因。
When the immigration deal eventually died, the glow of this victory at Breitbart is hard to overstate. At that party you heard about at the beginning of the show at the Breitbart headquarters in Washington, Jeff Sessions told the reporter who was there, Reid Cherlin, that one of the reasons he was such a fan of Breitbart News was that he believed they were the ones who had killed the immigration deal in Congress.
当移民协议最终流产时，布赖特巴特对这次胜利的欣喜程度难以言表。在节目开头提到的布赖特巴特华盛顿总部的派对上，杰夫·塞申斯告诉那里的记者里德·切林，他如此喜欢布赖特巴特新闻的原因之一是他相信是他们扼杀了国会的移民协议。
And then later, at that dinner at the Odeon, pens on his collar, didn't take off his coat, Bannon himself was taking credit for killing the leadership's dreams of immigration reform.
然后后来在 Odeon 的那次晚餐上，领子上别着笔、没脱外套的班农本人把扼杀领导层移民改革梦想的功劳揽在了自己身上。
We changed the narrative on amnesty. It was number 12 in May, and Memorial Day weekend, it was number 12. And when they did the Gallup poll about interests of the American people, it was not an issue. It was not an issue. The gang of eight was going through. And 90 days later, 120 days later, we've stopped the president of the United States.
我们改变了大赦的叙事。五月份它在议题列表上排第 12 位，阵亡将士纪念日周末，它排第 12 位。当他们做盖洛普民意调查关于美国人民的关注点时，它根本不是一个议题。它不是。八人帮的法案正在通过。而 90 天、120 天后，我们阻止了美国总统。
He's saying illegal immigration was 12th on a list of issues the American people cared about, according to a Gallup poll. And yet, he says, within a few months, we've stopped the President of the United States, meaning stopped President Obama's hope for an immigration deal.
他指的是根据盖洛普民意调查，非法移民在美国人民关心的议题列表中排第 12。然而，他说，在几个月内，我们阻止了美国总统，意思是阻止了奥巴马总统对移民协议的希望。
To Bannon and populists around the world, this was hugely empowering. It felt like the first domino knocking down the globalists. A few months later, Bannon was speaking to this far-right conference at the Vatican, and he was asked by an attendee in Vatican City about Eric Cantor's defeat in the 7th district of Virginia.
对于班农和世界各地的民粹主义者来说，这非常赋权。这感觉像是推倒全球主义者的第一块多米诺骨牌。几个月后，班农在梵蒂冈的一次极右翼会议上发言，梵蒂冈城的一名与会者问他关于埃里克·坎托在弗吉尼亚州第七选区的失败。
Eric Cantor just wasn't beaten. It was a landslide. And not one, outside of Breitbart-- we covered this for six months, day in and day out. Not one news site-- not Fox News, not POLITICO, no sites picked us up.
埃里克·坎托不仅是被击败了。那是压倒性的。而且除了布赖特巴特之外，没有一家媒体——我们报道了六个月，没日没夜。没有一家新闻网站——福克斯新闻、POLITICO，没有网站报道我们。
And the reason that this guy won is quite simple. Middle-class people and working-class people are tired of people like Eric Cantor, who say they're conservative, selling out their interest every day to crony capitalists.
而这家伙获胜的原因很简单。中产阶级和工人阶级厌倦了像埃里克·坎托这样的人，他们自称保守派，却每天把他们的利益出卖给裙带资本家。
If they could crush Eric Cantor, what couldn't they do? And it meant, when Donald Trump announced he was running for president, Steve Bannon and everyone else who felt vindicated by the Brat race thought he could win. They had already seen it in miniature. Like, here's filmmaker Ron Maxwell, who started this whole thing over Syria. He remembers when Trump announced his candidacy.
如果他们能碾碎埃里克·坎托，还有什么做不到的？这意味着，当唐纳德·特朗普宣布竞选总统时，史蒂夫·班农和其他所有在布拉特竞选中感到如释重负的人都认为他能赢。他们已经见识过这种缩影。像这位因叙利亚问题发起这一切的电影人罗恩·麦克斯韦，他记得特朗普宣布竞选的时候。
I saw that opening speech. And he started in ways that I admit are a little crude, but he brought the issue up of illegal immigration and sovereignty and trade. And he really got on my radar. I said, what a presidential candidate. Jeb Bush? Never. None of the guys. He sounded like Dave Brat. And then, soon after, I got on board. And I was on board for the whole campaign.
我看到了那场开场演讲。他以我承认有点粗鲁的方式开始，但他提出了非法移民、主权和贸易问题。他真的进入了我的雷达。我说，真是个总统候选人。杰布·布什 (Jeb Bush)？绝不可能。没有一个家伙像他那样。他听起来像戴夫·布拉特。随后不久，我加入了。我整个竞选期间都在支持他。
So he opened the Rolodex and started calling his people, his fellow populists in the media.
所以他打开了通讯录，开始给他的民粹主义同僚媒体朋友们打电话。
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our program. Coming up, he calls himself homeboy, but actually, I think the more accurate term is OG. Pat Buchanan in a minute from WBEZ Chicago when our program continues.
佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制片人之一。接下来，他自称是“老乡”，但我认为更准确的词是“OG” (原始老大哥)。帕特·布坎南 (Pat Buchanan)，稍后从芝加哥 WBEZ 电台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Beginning of Now, the story of how the people who put Donald Trump into the White House kicked into action in 2014. Meeting at parties, fomenting change, testing their political ideals in the congressional election to defeat Eric Cantor.
这是《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯 (Ira Glass)。今天的节目，《现在的开端》，讲述了将唐纳德·特朗普送进白宫的人们如何在 2014 年开始行动的故事。参加派对、煽动变革，在国会竞选中通过击败埃里克·坎托来测试他们的政治理想。
Though, some of the ideas that came to the fore in 2014 were uncannily familiar. And that's what we're talking about in this act.
不过，2014 年出现的一些想法出奇地熟悉。这就是我们在本幕中要谈论的内容。
Act Two, Who Tells Your Story?
第二幕：谁讲述你的故事？
Of everybody all over the world who watched the presidential campaign of Donald Trump last year, I think it's possible that the person who had the eeriest experience of it was Pat Buchanan, because he watched Trump sweep into office championing the same set of ideas that Buchanan ran for president with, and lost with, three different times-- 1992, '96, and 2000. Buchanan is probably best known for a speech that he gave at the 1992 Republican Convention that defined the party and him for a while, decrying that our country was in the middle of a cultural war with homosexuals, abortion, pornography, and radical feminism on one side, and Judeo-Christian values and Republicans on the other.
在去年关注唐纳德·特朗普总统竞选的全球所有观众中，我觉得最诡异的经历可能属于帕特·布坎南，因为他看着特朗普冲进白宫，倡导的正是他曾三次参加竞选并三次落败的同一套想法——1992 年、1996 年和 2000 年。布坎南最出名的是他在 1992 年共和党大会上发表的演讲，那场演讲定义了当时的共和党和他，公开声称我们的国家正处于一场文化战争之中，一边是同性恋、堕胎、色情和激进女权主义，另一边是犹太-基督教价值观和共和党人。
But his presidential campaigns were about more than that. Here he is in 1996.
但他的总统竞选远不止这些。这是他在 1996 年的表现。
We had one year of NAFTA. After one year, 300,000 jobs are gone. In addition to that, illegal immigration is soaring, narcotics pouring in.
我们经历了一年的北美自由贸易协定。一年后，30 万个就业机会没了。此外，非法移民激增，毒品涌入。
He's got Trump's whole agenda. Buchanan wanted to quit trade deals like NAFTA, stop companies from relocating factories overseas, get tough on immigration, phase out foreign aid, make our European allies pay for their own defense, build a wall on the Mexico border, stay out of foreign wars, recapture Washington from the moneyed political class and make it serve the forgotten middle class. And his slogan? You ready for this? America First.
他拥有特朗普的全部议程。布坎南想要退出像北美自由贸易协定这样的贸易协议，阻止公司将工厂迁往海外，对移民采取强硬态度，逐步淘汰对外援助，让我们的欧洲盟友支付自己的防务费用，在墨西哥边境修墙，远离外国战争，从金钱政治阶级手中夺回华盛顿，让它服务于被遗忘的中产阶级。而他的口号是什么？准备好了吗？“美国优先”。
So today we call for a new patriotism where Americans begin to put the needs of Americans first, for a new nationalism--
所以今天我们呼吁一种新的爱国主义，美国人开始把美国人的需求放在第一位，为一种新的民族主义——
So that "America first" passage, do you recognize what speech that was?
那么那个“美国优先”的片段，你认出那是哪场演讲吗？
It sounds like an announcement speech in New Hampshire, '92 or '96.
听起来像是 92 年或 96 年在新罕布什尔州的宣布竞选演讲。
It was his first presidential announcement in '92 in Concord. Producer Zoe Chace and I talked to him in his home in McLean, Virginia-- right next to the CIA, he told us. And it was pretty close. A house with white columns and a living room full of political souvenirs.
那是他在 92 年在康科德的第一次总统竞选宣布。制片人佐伊·蔡斯和我去弗吉尼亚州麦克林的家中拜访了他——他告诉我们这就在中情局旁边。确实很近。一栋带白色圆柱的房子，起居室里摆满了政治纪念品。
See over there, that piece of glazed glass there?
看到那边那块上釉的玻璃了吗？
A red, white, and blue stained glass windowpane was on the coffee table in the living room with his old slogan on it.
起居室咖啡桌上放着一块红白蓝相间的彩色玻璃窗格，上面写着他的旧口号。
"America First, 1992."
“美国优先，1992。”
A painting of Buchanan on the campaign bus in Iowa was above the fireplace. Photos of him traveling with Richard Nixon to China, when he was one of Nixon's closest advisers and strategists. A photo of him in a huddle with Ronald Reagan, back when he was in the inner circle of that White House. He was communications director. In the picture, they're going through a speech that he'd hastily rewritten after the Reykjavik arms talks ended badly.
壁炉上方挂着一幅布坎南在爱荷华州竞选大巴上的油画。他陪同理查德·尼克松 (Richard Nixon) 前往中国的照片，当时他是尼克松最亲密的顾问和策略师之一。还有他在罗纳德·里根 (Ronald Reagan) 那届白宫核心圈子里的照片。他是通讯联络主管。照片里，他们正在过一遍雷克雅未克军控会谈糟糕结束后他匆忙改写的讲稿。
And I had these cards. Put this card here, sir, and this card there. And we were trying to figure it out.
我有这些卡片。把这张卡片放在这儿，先生，那张放那儿。我们正试图弄清楚它。
Back when Ronald Reagan became president, it was widely acknowledged that the ideas that he had run on had been championed by Barry Goldwater when he ran and lost 16 years before that.
当罗纳德·里根成为总统时，人们普遍承认，他竞选的理念是巴里·戈德华特 (Barry Goldwater) 16 年前竞选并失败时所倡导的。
Donald Trump ran 16 years after Buchanan's final campaign. And for months now, Zoe and I have wondered why, except for an article here or there, Buchanan wasn't getting more credit. He told us, yeah, of course he noticed. It was his old platform right from the first day Trump announced.
唐纳德·特朗普在布坎南最后一次竞选 16 年后参选。这几个月来，佐伊和我一直在想，为什么除了零星的文章，布坎南没有得到更多的认可。他告诉我们，是的，他当然注意到了。从特朗普宣布竞选的第一天起，这就是他的旧纲领。
When he came down the escalator and he began talking about the trade deficits, he began talking about border security, about building a wall on the border. There was a Buchanan fence. It was economic nationalism or economic patriotism.
当他走下自动扶梯开始谈论贸易逆差，谈论边境安全，谈论在边境筑墙时。那是布坎南的栅栏。那是经济民族主义或经济爱国主义。
And so did you think like, hey, there it is? Or were you like hey, that's mine?
所以你当时是想“嘿，就是它了”？还是想“嘿，那是我的”？
Well, did you recognize it? Sure you did. When he says "America first," people were calling up. And so I was elated. I was all for Trump. And I come from a big family, nieces and nephews, and I got-- Uncle Pat is as happy as a p-- [LAUGHING] Uncle Pat is as happy as he could be watching what's going on. I mean, he really raised and elevated these issues.
嗯，你认出来了吗？当然了。当他说“美国优先”时，人们都在打电话。所以我很高兴。我完全支持特朗普。我来自一个大家庭，侄子侄女们，我有——“帕特叔叔真是太开心了……”(笑) 帕特叔叔看着这一切发生真是开心极了。我的意思是，他确实提升并放大了这些议题。
So you're not feeling overlooked?
所以你没觉得被忽略了吗？
No, not at all. I'm delighted. [LAUGHING]
不，一点也没有。我很高兴。(笑)
This is my last try with this "aren't you mad you didn't get credit?" question. When people talk about Trumpism, do you think like, hey, that's really Buchananism? Does that ever happen?
这是我最后一次问这个问题：“你不因为没得到认可而生气吗？”当人们谈论特朗普主义时，你会想“嘿，那其实是布坎南主义”吗？这种情况发生过吗？
No. Look, he won. He won. [LAUGHING]
没有。看，他赢了。他赢了。(笑)
Why do you think he was able to win on a platform so close to yours? What's changed?
你为什么认为他能以和你如此接近的纲领获胜？什么变了？
What's changed is, instead of 3 or 4 million illegals in the country, you had 11 and 1/2 million. They're in every city and town of America, and everybody suddenly realizes it. So it's now the disaster of these policies, the returns are in. When you lose a third of your manufacturing-- the greatest manufacturing power in the history of man-- everybody knows it. You can point to the reality-- you can point to the reality. You don't have to say this is what's going to happen if you do this. What we predicted came to pass.
变了的是，国内非法移民人数不再是 300 万或 400 万，而是 1150 万。他们遍布美国的每一个城市和城镇，每个人突然意识到了这一点。所以现在是这些政策的灾难，结果已经出来了。当你失去了三分之一的制造业——人类历史上最伟大的制造业力量——每个人都知道了。你可以指向现实——你可以指向现实。你不必说如果你们这样做会发生什么。我们预测的已经发生了。
So it's partly the issues. When he ran, Buchanan said the issues hadn't matured. But he readily acknowledged that Donald Trump was a special candidate and had all kinds of assets as a candidate that he hadn't had. Lots of money. He was better known. Buchanan mentioned Trump's plane a few times. Apparently, when you run for president, having your own airplane is very, very helpful.
所以部分是议题的原因。布坎南说当他竞选时，议题还不成熟。但他欣然承认特朗普是一位特别的候选人，作为候选人拥有他当时不具备的各种优势。大笔资金。他更出名。布坎南好几次提到了特朗普的飞机。显然，竞选总统时，有自己的飞机是非常、非常有帮助的。
Buchanan is an accomplished speechwriter and has written some famous presidential addresses that are careful and substantive and reach for grand themes. And I thought maybe Trump's off-the-cuff, not-deeply-informed-on-the-issues speaking style would be repellent to him, but he said no. He admires the spontaneity. The catchphrases.
布坎南是一位功成名就的演讲稿撰写人，写过一些著名的、严谨且富有实质内容并追求宏大主题的总统讲话。我原以为特朗普那种随性、对议题缺乏深度了解的演讲风格会让他反感，但他表示没有。他钦佩这种自发性。那些流行语。
Like, "and Mexico's going to pay for it." It was a very effective speech. And it's riveting, and it's very interesting and entertaining. He's a great candidate. There's no question about it.
比如“墨西哥会买单的”。那是一个非常有效的演讲。它很吸引人，非常有趣且富有娱乐性。他是一个伟大的候选人。毫无疑问。
When you were talking about seeing Trump's announcement coming down the escalator--
当你谈论看到特朗普宣布竞选时走下自动扶梯——
Mhm.
嗯。
When he talked about Mexican rapists, what was your reaction to that?
当他谈论墨西哥强奸犯时，你的反应是什么？
It was jolting. But it was-- you said that-- look, this is a guy that's not been sandpapered in politics. And it's raw. People have different assets. And he's got the ones that are-- from never having been in politics, it's got a real freshness to it.
那很令人震惊。但那是——你说了——看，这是一个没有在政治上被“打磨”过的人。而且很原始。人们有不同的优势。他拥有那些——因为从未从政，所以有种真正的新鲜感。
But did you have moments where you were just like, ooh, don't do that?
但你有过那种“噢，别那么做”的时刻吗？
Look, very early on, you caught on. And my feeling was, look, this is the last chance for the ideas that I advocated and championed, and they've matured, these issues have, and he's the sole individual that's carrying them, and this may be the last chance for them, so I'm going to cut him an awful lot of slack. He's, culturally and socially, a different kind of guy than I am, but I'm for him, and so I'm going to stick with him right to the end. And this is the last chance. And it is a chance. It's a long shot, but it is a chance.
看，很早以前，你就被抓住了。我的感觉是，看，这是我倡导和支持的理念的最后机会，这些议题已经成熟了，而他是唯一一个承载它们的人，这可能是这些理念的最后机会，所以我打算给他很大的宽容。他在文化和社会上和我不是同一种人，但我支持他，所以我打算支持他到底。这是最后的机会。这是一个机会。虽然希望渺茫，但它是一个机会。
When Buchanan says it's the last chance for these ideas, what he means is the country's problems have gotten so bad. So many jobs have gone overseas. So many factories have closed. And so many immigrants have already arrived. He's against that. In a number of books, he's written with alarm about America becoming a less white, more diverse country. "We are so divided already," he says, "and this divides us more."
当布坎南说这是这些理念的最后机会时，他的意思是国家的问题已经变得如此严重。太多的工作流向了海外。太多的工厂倒闭了。太多的移民已经到达了这里。他反对这一点。在好几本书里，他都对美国成为一个不再那么白人化、更多样化的国家表示担忧。“我们已经如此分裂，”他说，“而这使我们更加分裂。”
There's another one of his ideas that's come back in the age of Trump, championed by Steve Bannon and Jeff Sessions and a world of radio talk shows and websites and Breitbart News. This idea that immigrants are destroying our country's Judeo-Christian values because they don't assimilate because of multiculturalism.
布坎南还有另一个理念在特朗普时代回归了，受到史蒂夫·班农、杰夫·塞申斯以及电台脱口秀和布赖特巴特新闻世界的拥护。这种理念认为移民正在摧毁我们国家的犹太-基督教价值观，因为由于多元文化主义，他们不进行同化。
As I say, if you go back to 1960, the melting pot worked. The melting pot stopped working.
正如我所说，如果你回到 1960 年，大熔炉起作用了。大熔炉停止起作用了。
I don't know. When it comes to this country, when you make the argument of, whoa, our country was better off when we were majority white and Judeo-Christian?
我不知道。当谈到这个国家时，当你提出“我们的国家在我们是白人占多数和犹太-基督教占多数时过得更好”的论点时——
I think majority European, right.
我想是欧洲人占多数，对吧。
And why is it better? Just lay out the case. Why is that better?
为什么这更好？就摆出案例吧。为什么那更好？
Well, maybe it's preference. I feel more comfortable. I'm a homeboy, and I feel more comfortable with the folks you grew up with.
嗯，也许是偏好。我感觉更舒服。我是个“老乡”，和你们一起长大的人在一起我感觉更舒服。
I don't know. I mean, I say with respect, the people who I meet who are supposedly so different, they just never seem that different to me. They really don't. They seem very American to me.
我不知道。我是说，以尊重的态度，我遇到那些所谓的“如此不同”的人，他们在我看来似乎并没有那么不同。他们真的没有。他们在我看来非常美国化。
So he's a Davos guy. [LAUGHING]
所以他是个达沃斯精英。(笑)
No, don't have the money for that, sir. Definitely not.
不，先生，我可没那么多钱。绝对不是。
Davos-- that's the place in Switzerland where millionaire elites meet once a year supposedly to plot their globalist, free trade, one world, no borders, George Soros, Bono agenda. In this living room, that is a big diss.
达沃斯——那是瑞士那个百万富翁精英每年聚会一次的地方，据称是为了策划他们的全球主义、自由贸易、一个世界、无国界、索罗斯、博诺议程。在这个客厅里，那是一个大大的羞辱。
The other problem from Buchanan's perspective, with the country becoming less white, is political. Buchanan's been a serious student of political demographics. He's one of the people who rose from the ashes of Goldwater's defeat in 1964 and figured out a new combination of demographic groups that could propel Richard Nixon into the White House in 1968.
从布坎南的角度来看，另一个关于国家变得不那么白人化的问题是政治性的。布坎南一直是一个认真的政治人口统计学生。他是从 1964 年戈德华特失败的灰烬中崛起、找出了一组新的人口统计组合从而在 1968 年将理查德·尼克松推入白宫的人之一。
And when he looks at the demographics today, he considers the possibility of more Latinos and other immigrants becoming part of the electorate. He agrees with the Republicans that you've heard this hour who believe that that does not look good for their party.
当他审视今天的人口结构时，他考虑了更多拉丁裔和其他移民成为选民的可能性。他同意你们这一小时听到的共和党人的观点，即这对比他们的党来说看起来不太妙。
North Carolina is shifting. Georgia is shifting demographically. The American Southwest is shifting. The Hispanic vote is growing. It's going to be almost impossible to win. Trump won, but he lost by 3 million votes. And 80,000 votes the other way and we'd still be talking about the eternal lock the Democratic Party's got on the presidency. In other words, they have a problem, the Republican Party. It's far harder for me to solve than the one I saw after Barry Goldwater. You could see the path-- the path up the mountainside there. I don't see it now.
北卡罗来纳州正在发生变化。乔治亚州的人口结构正在发生变化。美国西南部正在发生变化。西班牙裔选民在增长。获胜将几乎不可能。特朗普赢了，但他输掉了 300 万张选票。如果选票反向 8 万张，我们就还在谈论民主党对总统职位的永恒锁定。换句话说，他们有问题，共和党。这比我在巴里·戈德华特之后看到的更难解决。你可以看到那条路——山坡上的那条路。我现在看不到了。
There's another way that Trump represents the last chance for Buchanan's ideas. If the Republican Party does not attract more nonwhite voters, it's hard to see how they're going to continue to win the White House. And this is something really interesting about where Republicans are right now, even in this moment of triumph they're having, where they have the White House and both houses of Congress and so many state houses and governor's mansions around the country.
特朗普代表布坎南理念的最后机会还有另一种方式。如果共和党不能吸引更多非白人选民，很难看出他们将如何继续赢得总统职位。这关于共和党人现在所处的位置，即使在他们享受这一胜利的时刻，即他们拥有白宫、国会两院以及全国各地的那么多州议会和州长办公室时，这也是一件非常有趣的事情。
When they look at the future, they're still looking down the barrel of the same dilemma they had in 2014, back at the beginning of now. The party is still wrestling with the same issue that got Eric Cantor knocked out of office. They have to choose between two policies, neither of which seems like it solves their national political problems. If they stay tough on immigration, they think they'll kiss off most of the Latino vote, which will doom them. Though, if they provide a path to citizenship, they believe those new Latino voters mostly will be Democrats, and that'll doom them.
当他们审视未来时，他们仍然面临着与 2014 年、即“现在开端”时同样的困境。该党仍在纠缠于让埃里克·坎托下台的同一个议题。他们必须在两项政策之间做出选择，而这两项政策似乎都无法解决他们的全国政治问题。如果他们对移民保持强硬，他们认为他们会放弃大部分拉丁裔选票，这将毁掉他们。尽管，如果他们提供获得公民身份的途径，他们相信那些新的拉丁裔选民大部分会是民主党人，那也会毁掉他们。
So what do you think the Republican Party should do? Should they try to reach out beyond the white vote that they have?
所以你认为共和党应该怎么做？他们应该试图接触他们拥有的白人选票之外的人吗？
I think economic nationalism is the future-- the kind of appeal Trump made to nationalism-- America first.
我认为经济民族主义才是未来——特朗普那种向民族主义的呼吁——美国优先。
To be clear, he's saying, do everything you can to keep jobs in the US. Quit trade deals like NAFTA. Impose tariffs on imported goods. And if that boosts the economy, it's going to help everybody and appeal not just to white people, but voters of all races who might decide then to vote Republican. It's not white nationalism, he says.
明确地说，他是在说：竭尽所能把工作留在美国。退出像北美自由贸易协定这样的贸易协议。对进口商品征收关税。如果这能促进经济，它将帮助每个人，不仅吸引白人，还会吸引所有种族的选民，他们可能随后决定投票给共和党。他说，这并不是白人民族主义。
You can't have white nationalists if they're diminishing as a share of the population. It's American nationalism. The one winning hand the Republicans have, I think, is going to be American nationalism.
如果他们占人口比例的份额在减少，你就不能拥有白人民族主义。这是美国民族主义。我认为共和党拥有的唯一获胜的一手牌将是美国民族主义。
If that works, it's basically more Trumpism, more Buchananism going forward into the future. Though, Buchanan, he's the first to admit, is a pessimist. This really might not work, he says. The demographic problems the party's facing are so profound. And if this doesn't work, the now that we're in right now-- the whole "Donald Trump, America first, reject the rest of the world, wall up the borders" America-- that will not be the future, for the country or the party. It'll just be a blip.
如果这行得通，基本上就是更多的特朗普主义、更多的布坎南主义走向未来。尽管布坎南自己承认是一个悲观主义者。他说，这真的可能行不通。该党面临的人口问题如此深远。如果这行不通，我们现在身处的当下——整个“唐纳德·特朗普、美国优先、拒绝世界其他地区、边境筑墙”的美国——将不会是未来，对于国家或政党来说。它只会是一个瞬间。
Pat Buchanan's newest book, by the way, is history that he participated in himself. It's called Nixon's White House Wars-- The Battles That Made and Broke a President and Divided America Forever. It comes out in a week.
顺便说一下，帕特·布坎南的新书是他自己参与的历史。书名叫《尼克松的白宫战争——塑造与打破总统并将美国永远分裂的战斗》。一周后出版。
Let's close out today with one last clip. This is the night before the 1996 Republican Convention in San Diego. The candidate's telling the crowd that, even though he didn't win the Republican nomination, his ideas about America first, they still had a future.
最后让我们用最后一个片段来结束今天。这是 1996 年圣地亚哥共和党全国大会的前夜。候选人告诉人群，即使他没有赢得共和党提名，他关于“美国优先”的想法依然有未来。
Before our eyes and before their eyes, this party is becoming a Buchanan Party. The old era is over. The old order--
在我们眼前，在他们眼前，这个党正在成为一个“布坎南党”。旧时代结束了。旧秩序——
[APPLAUDING WILDLY]
[疯狂鼓掌]
The old order is passing away. But within this party, a new party is being born. God willing, God willing, we will be there at its birth, and one day, the stone the builders rejected shall become the cornerstone.
旧秩序正在过去。但在这个党内，一个新的党正在诞生。上帝保佑，上帝保佑，我们将见证它的诞生，终有一天，建筑工人拒绝的那块石头将成为基石。
[MUSIC - "HOW IT STARTS" BY CAMEO CULTURE]
[音乐 - CAMEO CULTURE 的《一切是如何开始的》]
Our program was produced today by our senior producer, Brian Reed. Our staff includes Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Kimberly Henderson, Stephanie Foo, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Research help today from Christopher Swetala and Benjamin Phelan. Music help today from Damien Graef.
今天的节目由我们的高级制片人布莱恩·里德 (Brian Reed) 制作。我们的员工包括苏珊·伯顿 (Susan Burton)、佐伊·蔡斯、达纳·奇维斯 (Dana Chivvis)、肖恩·科尔 (Sean Cole)、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德 (Whitney Dangerfield)、尼尔·德拉明 (Neil Drumming)、金伯利·亨德森 (Kimberly Henderson)、斯蒂芬妮·福 (Stephanie Foo)、米基·米克 (Miki Meek)、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔 (Jonathan Menjivar)、马特·蒂尔尼 (Matt Tierney)、朱莉·惠特克 (Julie Whitaker) 和黛安·吴 (Diane Wu)。今天的调研帮助来自克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉 (Christopher Swetala) 和本杰明·费兰 (Benjamin Phelan)。今天的音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫 (Damien Graef)。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he came with me to synagogue for Passover this year. He did not enjoy it.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《这就是美国生活》由 PRX 公共广播交易中心发送给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚 (Torey Malatia) 先生。你们知道吗，今年逾越节他跟我一起去了犹太教堂。他一点也没享受。
This Cantor is the worst!
这个坎托是最烂的！
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《这就是美国生活》的故事。